I’m going to show you
two very short adverts.
My question is:
which is louder?
This video is sponsored by NordVPN.
THIS VIDEO IS SPONSORED BY NORDVPN!
Here’s the volume of the
nice, calm one.
The second one?
With the shouting,
the background noise,
the music?
If you’re measuring volume
purely by decibels,
then it was lower.
But it definitely
sounded louder.
To explain that,
we need to start
at the beginning:
what does it mean for
something to be loud?
Let’s say a tree falls
in the forest.
The tree causes
the air to move,
both by pushing
it out the way,
but also by the tree
and the things around it
vibrating as they deal with
all the forces involved.
Those vibrations are
transferred into the air.
The actual air itself
is not travelling from the
crashing tree to your ears,
but rather it’s a wave
caused by air molecules
bumping into each other.
And if you’re standing nearby,
then bits of that wave
get funnelled
by the flappy bit of your ear,
the pinna, into your ear canal.
The waves get to your eardrum,
and it vibrates in turn,
just a tiny, tiny amount.
Behind it, there’s the three
smallest bones in the human body:
the hammer, anvil, and stirrup.
They amplify those vibrations
through leverage,
and deliver these vibrations
into the cochlea,
shaped like a snail shell,
which converts it into
electrical impulses
that get interpreted by the brain.
If you ask a physicist,
those air movements are sound.
Ask a psychologist,
and they’ll say that
until those movements get
interpreted by the brain,
it’s just stuff moving,
because sound is in your head,
it’s an experience.
If the tree falls in the forest
and no-one’s there to listen,
a physicist says there’s sound,
a psychologist says there isn’t.
And both of them are correct
because they’re using the same
word to mean different things,
which is part of why it takes
so long to answer
what seems like a simple question.
So. Let’s talk about that wave.
It’s got two important values:
the amount of pressure for each peak,
the amplitude;
and the time between each
peak arriving, the frequency.
We’ll start with the amplitude.
Pressure is measured in pascals,
and regular air at about sea level
has a pressure of somewhere around
100,000 pascals:
that’s the weight of all the
atmosphere above pushing down.
Our ears can detect a fluctuation
of about 20 micropascals.
A whisper in your ear would be
about 2 millipascals,
and traffic noise
about 200 millipascals.
And someone screaming at the
top of their voice,
directly into your ear,
is around 20 pascals,
which is well into the sorts of
pressure that can cause hearing loss.
Okay, as you might have noticed,
that’s not a particularly useful graph,
because the differences
in scale are enormous,
even if we get rid of the
ambient pressure at the top.
So instead, let’s use a
logarithmic scale,
which means that each block
going vertically
is ten times the previous one.
That’s much clearer:
just remember,
this is a 10 times
jump in pressure,
and so’s this,
and so’s this.
That’s how decibels work.
That minimum that humans can
detect, 20 micropascals,
is taken as 0 bels,
and then each 10-times increase
in pressure adds two bels,
and we generally use
tenths of those,
so each 10-times increase
is another 20 decibels.
And I know, a load of sound engineers
and techies are already in the comments
going “no, no, each ten times increase
is 10 decibels, you fool!”
and here’s reason two why this
is so difficult to answer:
there are multiple decibel scales!
Because sound engineers
talk about intensity,
the amount of power transmitted,
not the amount of actual pressure
on your eardrum,
those two things are proportional,
and look, it doesn’t matter for this,
just …blame mathematicians, okay?
The important thing is:
your brain doesn’t interpret
“ten times more change in pressure”
to mean “ten times as loud”.
Sure, traffic noise feels
louder than a whisper,
but I don’t think many people
would guess that the amplitude
is a hundred times more pressure.
That’s why we use decibels,
a logarithmic scale matches
how we think about sound.
Hold that thought.
That’s amplitude dealt with.
Next is frequency.
And that’s easy to define:
it’s just the number of peaks per second,
or ‘hertz’.
The human ear can detect roughly
from 20 Hz through to 20,000 Hz,
although that starts to decrease
as people get older.
The sound wave is going to be
much more complex, of course,
it’s usually not transmitting
just a single frequency,
but let’s not get into the
maths of that too much!
We’re particularly sensitive to the
range between 2,000 and 5,000 Hz,
which means our brains perceive
those frequencies as being louder.
In 1933, Harvey Fletcher and
Wilden A. Munson published this,
which became known as the
Fletcher-Munson curve.
They played different sounds
at different levels
and noted how their test subjects
perceived that sound.
The curve has been updated and
refined over time,
and now it’s usually called
the Equal Loudness Contour.
So if you want this tone...
and this tone...
to feel as loud as each other,
you need to play the low one…
I want to say louder,
but that’s not right.
You’d need to play the low one
with greater amplitude.
And of course, science has a
measuring system for this too.
Audio engineers and broadcast companies
came up with LUFS,
Loudness Units Full Scale.
The calculations for this take
the loudness contour into account,
along with how long
the loud sounds last.
LUFS are a scientific way to measure
how loud something should feel,
not how much the air
happens to be moving.
If you’re making a video
for YouTube or Netflix,
or music for Spotify or iTunes,
there are guides for you
to follow.
YouTube asks you to
aim for -14 LUFS
– the units are kinda arbitrary,
it’s just a number.
If you upload something that’s
louder than that,
they’ll just turn the player’s
volume setting down automatically,
in the background, so people
don’t suddenly get startled
if one video or music track
is louder than another.
So that means if you’re making
a movie or a TV show,
and you want your loud sounds
to have impact,
you can’t turn them up
above the limit,
you have to turn the dialog and speech
and all the other sounds down.
Not too much, that’ll also
cause problems, but enough
that when the big explosion happens,
it’s noticeable. It's audible.
But advertisers don’t need
or want the nuance,
they just want to be heard,
they usually want to be as loud
as they can be throughout.
The European Union specifies -23 LUFS
as its target for broadcasters,
to try and keep adverts and
programmes at the same loudness.
The US has no specific guidelines
but says that broadcasters
should try to match the two –
although that rule is
rarely, if ever, enforced.
All of which is to say that the whisper
of that first advert?
The sound waves had higher amplitude,
your eardrum will have vibrated
further back and forth.
But it didn’t feel as loud.
There were more decibels,
but fewer LUFS.
And these days,
it’s the LUFS that matter.
SERIOUSLY. THIS NORDVPN ADVERT
HAS LOWER SOUND PRESSURE
than this one does.
AND I’M HAPPY TO
ENDORSE NORDVPN
because I keep finding it
actually useful.
SOME AMERICAN SITES BLOCK
EUROPEAN VISITORS ENTIRELY
because they can’t be bothered to deal
with the privacy laws over here.
Or maybe you want to access content
WITHOUT YOUR INTERNET PROVIDER,
OR YOUR SCHOOL, BEING ABLE TO TRACK
WHICH WEBSITES YOU’RE CONNECTING TO.
OR MAYBE YOU JUST WANT TO PRETEND
YOU’RE IN ANOTHER COUNTRY
SO YOU CAN WATCH STUFF FROM THERE.
Just check the streaming service’s
terms and conditions first.
NORDVPN’S MAGIC BUTTON
LETS YOU PRETEND
YOU’RE IN ONE OF AROUND 60 COUNTRIES,
on your phone, tablet, and computer,
UP TO SIX DEVICES AT A TIME.
And there’s a 30-day money-back guarantee
if you want to test it out.
YOU CAN GO TO nordvpn.com/tomscott,
CLICK THE LINK IN THE DESCRIPTION,
or scan the QR code
to find the best deal
they’re currently offering.
MY VOICE IS TIRED.
Also, it's really hot out here.